what's the difference between a telecan
and a cuckoo can and what does any of
this have to do with black panther keep
watching to find out
with the release of the new trailer for
Black Panther wakanda forever fans are
excited to see actor to know chuerta
take on the role of Namor the Submariner
Namor who was Marvel's first comic book
superhero has never appeared in live
action before and his debut will come
with a Twist in the comics he hails from
Atlantis but in the MCU his home will be
in underwater land known as talukan this
is a sensible Choice by Marvel Studios
one that will prevent confusion for dceu
and MCU fans when it comes to
similarities between wakanda forever and
Aquaman talican is most likely a
reference to the Aztec Paradise of
tulalocan a level of the afterlife
reserved for anyone who dies a
water-related death clallican is ruled
over by plawlock the Aztec god of rain
and thunder this tweak to the city of
Neymar's origin opens a lot of
possibilities for Neymar's character and
it may also explain the new nickname
given to the character in The recently
released trailer in the trailer mbaku
says this of Namor they called him oh
God
never servant God cuckoo can is the name
for a feathered serpent God in the
mythologies of many cultures in
mesoamerica including the Aztecs
although his Aztec Incarnation is better
known as the even harder to pronounce
say okatol told pizzin quetzalcoat could
you repeat that sir say alcatal told
pizzin quetzalcoat quetzalcoat is said
to be from Tallinn the capital of the
Toltec civilization that preceded the
Aztecs one notable moment in the trailer
finds Neymar painting a mural on the
wall of a building using a split conch
shell to hold his paint it's likely that
this particular shell was chosen on
purpose as The Conch is an item often
associated with kukulkan a conch often
associated with Key West or the
Caribbean has its shell pictorial often
seen on statues and images of aikidal
the wind God incarnation of kukulkan
interestingly though kukukan and kalak
aren't technically the same God in Aztec
mythology as talak is the god of rain
and kokan is merely known to be a
bringer it seems that the movie might be
trying to fuse together the mythologies
between these two figures this could
explain the character's ability to fly
which is somewhat of mystery in the
comics as neither of his parents possess
that ability it also explains the
headdress the character has been seen
wearing in images from the movie such as
on the cover of the November issue of
Empire magazine wakanda forever is
clearly bringing a great deal of Aztec
mythology into this Sequel and hopefully
it will provide as Rich of a backstory
as the first film gave to wakanda itself
and since many peoples believed that
kukul Khan was a kind of cultural savior
destined to return to them it's possible
that even the people of wakanda have
foretold this coming we'll all see the
results when wakanda forever hits
theaters on November 11th
[Music]